la france fait-elle un peu trop de zèle
pour arrêter des manifestants
c'est l'avis de l' ong amnesty
international son enquête climat
d'insécurité totale et la seconde
qu'elle publie sur ce thème ce rapport
si blessant 42 arrestations lors de la
manifestation contre le projet de loi
sur la sécurité globale
elle a lieu le 12 décembre amnesty
s'indignent les détentions de
manifestants ont eu lieu en l'absence
d'éléments permettant raisonnablement de
penser qu'ils avaient pu commettre une
infraction
ce qui s'apparente à des détentions
arbitraires le 12 décembre plusieurs
milliers de manifestants s'étaient
rassemblés pacifiquement pour protester
contre le projet de loi notamment
l'article 24 réprimant la diffusion
malveillantes dix vaches des forces de
l'ordre la manifestation avait été
déclarée entre 5000 et 10000 personnes
avaient défilé entre la place du
châtelet et la place de la république à
paris ici même
ce jour là la préfecture de police a
déclaré qu'elle est intervenu
régulièrement pour interpeller des
éléments radicaux et empêcher la
constitution d'un black blocks en
l'occurrence pour une fois pas
d'incident à déplorer et gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur s'était
immédiatement félicitées des 140 deux
interpellations
or c'est rester à la loi plusieurs
centaines de casseurs étaient venus pour
commettre des violences
la stratégie de fermeté anti casseurs
cent quarante deux interpellations et
encadrement du cortège a permis de les
en empêcher de protéger les commerçants
il a été reproché à ces individus un
délit de participation à un groupement
on veut de la préparation de violences
ou encore un refus de dispersion après
sommation elle n'a pourtant pas été
retrouvé d'armes
si ce n'est un casque de moto des
lunettes de plongée les manifestants ont
été menottées puis privé de liberté
entre 5h et plus de 24 heures
et en guise de black block ou d'éléments
radicaux qui retrouve-t-on en cellule
une travailleuse sociale
dix-neuf mineurs un reporter et
finalement sur les 142 interpellé 80 %
des dossiers ont été classés sans suite
tout ça pour ça du côté des syndicats
policiers que pense-t-on des événements
de cette journée comptant la préfecture
de police et les personnes qui donne les
ordres
donc il ya eu des charges complètement
illégal cirque ils ont une et policiers
sur le terrain en vue d ordre de charger
des manifestants pacifiques
des fois avec des blessures graves qui
ont abouti à des interpellations aussi
illégal est effectivement et des fois il
peut y avoir quelques erreurs
d'appréciation d'un penser que la
personne a fait quelque chose c'est
possible et qu'on à 80 % de personnes
qui sont relâchés
c'est qu'on est nuls donc si on est nul
c'est qu'on nous demande d'interpeller
de façon préventive des gens comme dans
minority report ya surtout une volonté
que les gens ne manifestent pas je
rappelle quand même que monsieur dit
lallement préfet de police a été le seul
préfet de police à avoir réussi à
interdire une manifestation de 30
minutes après son début sur le terrain
les policiers ne savent pas quand ils
reçoivent des ordres il doit faire
confiance à la salle de commandement
c'est ce qu'on n'arrive pas de répéter
après les gens sont interpellés avec des
lois qui sont des loi fourre-tout et des
lois qui sont très floues et après c'est
une volonté politique parce que monsieur
darmana fait des tweets laissant
sous-entendre que mais quand on regarde
derrière c'est pas du tout vrai et oui
nos ong épingle le ministre de
l'intérieur pour 100 tweets incriminants
quid de la présomption d'innocence il a
assimilé les personnes interpellées à
des casseurs avant même que l'enquêté
n'ait été menée
quoi qu'il en soit amenée ci recommande
de ne placer une personne en garde à vue
que lorsqu'il existe un motif
raisonnable de penser qu'elle a commis
une infraction pénale
cela éviterait en effet de les laisser
croupir en cellule puis de les relâcher
parce qu'ils ne sont coupables de rien à
moins que manifester son opinion ne soit
devenu un délit